so the purpose the reason why the
alliance members were at the train
station this morning and boarding the
train was to do
what we refer to as a routine
interdiction check in other words um
they were checking
for
illegal guns
money
drugs this is something they do as i
said routinely at pretty much all
transit hubs it's not just trains it
involves buses they're at the airports
as well
so what happened is several officers
boarded the train
and they ultimately made contact with
two individuals who were on the second
level of this is a double-decker car on
the amtrak train
they
detained
basically one individual
and while they were dealing with one
individual a second individual hispanic
male by appearance somewhere in his 20s
to 30s
produced a handgun
and opened fire
on the officers
there's a tpd officer again part of this
alliance group that was on the platform
and he heard the rounds
and
ran directly into the dangerous
situation in order to be whatever
possible help he could as he entered
into the train
he was
also shot
at that point
the suspect after exchanging rounds with
the officers barricaded himself in
the bathroom which is on the lower level
of one of the basically two cars where
this happens i think the bathrooms on
one car and then the
passengers that where this mostly
happened was in the other car
um
so ultimately
some time went on there wasn't clarity
whether the suspect was still alive or
not whether he had been shot or not but
ultimately it was determined that the
suspect in the bathroom
was in fact deceased
and he was declared dead at the scene
um
so the seriously injured
dea officer keeping in mind there's one
officer who was deceased but the
seriously injured dea officer
was then evacuated from the train
and taken
by
tpd officers in the back of a patrol car
in fact because they were trying to move
as expeditiously as possible taken to
the hospital here where we're at banner
umc
um the other officers uh who were
injured uh were were taken by ems to the
same hospital here
so
i really want to reflect
first on the terrible tragedy that this
is
not just for the dea obviously but for
everyone in law enforcement it's really
horrific and we're all
just coming to terms with just how
terrible a loss this is
but i also want to reflect on the really
heroic actions of the officers at the
scene who
literally ran towards the danger into
the car where there was an active
shooting situation going on
and in fact were not only able to
evacuate
the critically injured officer and get
the other officers off the train but
also
and very importantly assure that none of
the passengers on the train and we're
not quite clear on how many we know
roughly that in
the car that most of this occurred in
they were give or take a dozen other
passengers but
they were able
we were able to make sure that they were
safe so there were no passengers on the
train
who were injured nor were there any
bystanders
in or around the platform including
folks who work at the street at the
train station
um
so i i just think it's
kind of incredible here that there
weren't other people that were hurt even
though
we're completely
so saddened by the loss of the officer
our officer
is
here as i mentioned being treated
his condition is stable
he's
going to be here for observation
overnight
but we're not providing any more
information about the names or specifics
about the injuries of any of these three
officers and as i said there's very
limited information that um i'll be able
to provide although i'll do my best to
take
a few questions
were the suspects uh they boarded here
in onto the train in tucson or if
they've boarded some other timeline in
los angeles or somewhere
yeah i
not only don't know the answer to that
question but it's really not something i
could speak to at this point of the
investigation what was the destination
of the train uh i'm sorry i don't know
that we're still working to figure out
exactly where the train was coming from
where it was headed to all we know is
that it was stationary at the tucson
train stations i know you mentioned this
earlier but
one person you said was detained what
was found
uh can't speak to anything that was
found or any of the specifics regarding
that individual who was detained but he
is in custody at this
how often the time narcotics alliance
goes out there to do this on the trains
that surveillance
i can't speak to what their schedule is
all i can tell you is that they do
routine interdiction efforts not only on
trains but as i said also on
buses and involving planes at the
airport has it been determined if the
deceased subject died by his own hand or
if it was
during the fire fight that's still under
active investigation
no i'm afraid i don't right now
i believe so but i can't confirm that
so did the entire incident happen
on the train or were there shots
actually fired outside of the train as
well
my understanding is that the incident
unfolded and occurred on the train
although there were officers from
outside of the train who rushed into the
train
so there was an evacuation of persons
and at that point this was still a very
active situation with
the suspect still firing around
so i just want to confirm that we've got
one dh one dea agent who's passed away
one who's in serious
condition and a tpd
officer who's in stable condition
i think you're pretty close that's
that's right a dea officer who
is deceased another dea officer who's in
critical condition and a tucson police
officer who's in stable condition but is
being admitted
is there any uh is there any indication
right now what the uh what that initial
interaction with the officers and that
suspect they ended up containing what
that was about was it narcotics involved
was it
firearms i just don't know that yet
tucson police was the agency who
responded and i can tell you
having
been working at that time
this was put out as a city-wide response
there were over 50 officers who
responded to the scene
i think their response was phenomenal
and again the officers that worked not
only to assure the safety of the
passengers on the train and the others
on the platform but also who were
responsible for getting at least one of
the injured parties to the hospital i
have nothing but
admiration for their courage really
heroics under the situation
no i'm sorry i can't do that right now
okay thank you all very much i
appreciate it